FOR.
H, THAS.NOW.S EDITOR-IN-CHIEF AN
UNR OF
WEEKLY ANSSIA LAS DID YNE
TO LEAVEIDED TO E LAWYERE I HADV
AT THEND OF JULY ACCUSED MIS CH
STORIESFACT THE RUSBO CI>> AND.
>>A CRIME.
E INRO- THAT I WASY
BECAUSE DISINFORMATION WASN'T
PUBLISHED ON THE MINISTER OF
DEFENSE WEBSITE.T PUBLF WECAUSE
MR.AL
REPARATION.
VLTALKING ES YOU
ABOU
300,00N TROOP SNZ.
>> IT SAYST
IS TRYING  S AGAINWI ZELENSKYY.
S  EXACTSE
HE KNOWS HE' WAR.BAN IS FIGHTIN
FOR HIS SURVIVAL AA PRESEN PERS.
F IN HIS
AND THE REST OE
WORLD.
BRET IT'S
IR BECAUSE OF SANCTIONS THEY
LOST T PROPERTIES.HI
BEING LL>> ABSOLUTELY, HE
VE
VUERSAE
BOUT CAWING UP 300,000  T
IS THAT A F WIDESPREAD CTION?IGI
FEDERATION IN ALL OF OUR1 TIMEZT
THEY KNOW 00
PERATE
THE MAJORITY OF E WHO
ARE MALE AOI
DRAFT CARD AND MOVTO THE ARMY.
OTHERS WILL BEF
SPREADING NF ABOUT
THE RUSSIALIKELY
N JAIL OR FID AN
SO IT IS THERE REAL HERS VERY,
NT.E IT AE LANDS WEEN
RUIA C
SS KAZHS
MONG
YOU SE0 LO
PEOPLE ARE RUN THERE. IMPOSBL A
TICKET
L
OF
PEOPLE AREING, YOU KNO,
0 JUST T
ARMENIA. A 4-HOUHT IT IS TO SAYR
BECAUSE PE MY FELLOW TIZENS UND
CANNOT KILL,N'T
LLS